I think there's an obvious trade-off we
can't have you know 728 billion people
on the planet all of them living like
Americans so one of the problems we're
going to have to address as a society is
how do you convince people in the most
advanced societies who are consuming
most of the resources to to essentially
except except for I regard is not
necessarily a diminution of their
lifestyles but a diminution of their
ostentation or to put it in really crude
terms how do you get more Americans and
Europeans to have a much much smaller
carbon footprint right now without
thinking that that requires us all to
live in tiny homes that requires us all
to write bicycles to work or things like
that but rather can we be happy about a
different lifestyle where maybe the
12,000 foot McMansion is not the
American dream and that we all accept
that many more people are going to have
to live in some parts of their lives in
a much more constrained fashion I
actually regard that as a social and
cultural problem that we are again just
beginning to have to think about and
it's not one that's going to sit well
with many Americans where we tend to
thinking we're Americans were entitled
to whatever we can afford